what is one tip you would give if I
wanted to like you know become known and
like famous or something well why do you
want to become famous
it's cool but is it
no probably not
what you really want to do is when you
make your videos make sure you're making
them for yourself and it's something you
actually believe in not a video that
you're doing because you think it will
do good you understand too many people
make videos that they think will get
views
but it's not really in their soul so if
you decide to get into that world when
you make videos make sure it's something
you actually want to make
you got it yeah my man thank you